ils sont médecins sages femmes
infirmiers chirurgiens ou pharmacien pas
moins de sept ordres professionnels de
la santé signa un communiqué au vitriol
contre la grande distribution
en cause la mise en vente de masques
dans les grandes enseignes à partir de
lundi prochain
comment nos patients notamment les plus
fragiles acquis l'ont expliqué jusqu'à
hier qu'il ne pourrait bénéficier d'une
protection adaptée
vont-ils comprendre que ce qui
n'existait pas hier tombe à profusion
aujourd'hui 100 millions par ici
50 millions par là qui dit mieux c'est
la surenchère de l'indécence entre les
lignes
les soignants reprochent à la grande
distribution la marchandisation des
équipements de protection
en d'autres termes d'avoir accumulé les
stocks au lieu de les mettre à
disposition pour les mettre en vente à
partir du 4 mai aujourd'hui la
consternation s'allie au dégoût où
étaient ces masques quand nos médecins
nos infirmiers nos pharmaciens nos
chirurgiens dentistes nos masseurs
kinésithérapeutes nos pédicure podologue
nos sages femmes mais aussi tous nos
personnels en prise directe avec la
maladie tremblay est tombé chaque matin
la fédération du commerce et de la
distribution dément ces accusations
selon elle il est trop facile de charger
les grandes enseignes
les enseignes de la grande distribution
ne sont pas et n'ont jamais été en
charge de l'achat et de la fourniture de
masques pour les soignants leur
attribuer les difficultés
d'approvisionnement est donc faux et
malhonnête
il n'y a pas de stock caché le
gouvernement a décidé de plafonner le
prix des masques chirurgicaux
ils seront vendus 95 centimes d'euro
l'unité au maximum en revanche aucune
limite de prix n'est prévu pour les
masque en tissu